next up our fellow
next up our fellow cruise lovers out
there we have huge news for you cnn
reports that you can now make cruise in
your lifestyle that's right you can
actually be living on a cruise ship some
retirees are setting sail for their
golden years by planning a wall-to-wall
cruise one couple the berks from seattle
have already booked 86 days at sea for
2022 for just 89 bucks per day both of
them get room food entertainment and
that includes gratuity and taxes and
they get to see the world
and you don't have to retire some cruise
lines are offering full residences at
sea and you can stay on their ship
year-round and bring your remote work
because they have great wi-fi
uh-huh uh-huh i love this rossi thought
season three on the seas all aboard come
on oh my
god you know
[Applause]
please can you please please can i be
the cruise director please don't put me
to work i'll do anything like julie yeah
like just like jewelry
i love you can go to finland
and like explore that area
the cruise line industry
i just think it's so amazing and again
if anybody's intimidated with planning i
just feel like you get on you pick your
destinations they figure it out for you
they kind of take that fear factor out
of it i love it i'm so in i'm so in i
feel like i was a man made to cruise you
know how i love a buffet i do
and i love
visiting multiple locations and
unpacking one time that's why i love
cruises too and i did the math so it's
89 a day so say you went for a month
around 30 days it is 2 670
that for two people that's room board
buffet those little towel swans um
shows
piano bars everything pools slides
uh i'll see you on board everybody thank
you so much
let's go on a cruise
can you imagine us on a cruise i mean
we've rved we've been parked at this
desk for two years i'm serious let's go
on a cruise i can't think of anything
more fun than anyone more fun to do it
with i'm in i'm going to get you a
little uh lifesaver uh thing i'm gonna
throw over you matching me we're in girl
can you imagine the captain
well next up our fellow cruise lovers
out there we have huge news for you cnn
reports that you can now make cruise in
your lifestyle that's right you can
actually be living on a cruise ship some
retirees are setting sail for their
golden years by planning a wall-to-wall
cruise
one couple the berks from seattle have
already booked 86 days at sea for 2022
for just 89 bucks per day both of them
get room food entertainment and that
includes gratuity and taxes and they get
to see the world
and you don't have to retire some cruise
lines are offering full residences at
sea and you can stay on their ship
year-round and bring your remote work
because they have great wi-fi
uh-huh uh-huh i love this rossi thought
season three on the seas all aboard come
on oh my god
you know
[Applause]
please come please please can i be the
cruise director please don't put me to
work i'll do anything like julie yeah
like just like that
i love you can go to finland
and like explore that area the cruise
line industry it i just think it's so
amazing and again if anybody's
intimidated with planning i just feel
like you get on you pick your
destinations they figure it out for you
they kind of take that fear factor out
of it i love it i'm so in i'm so in i
feel like i was a man made to cruise you
know how i love a buffet i do
and i love uh visiting multiple
locations and unpacking one time that's
why i love cruises too and i did the
math so it's 89 a day so say you went
for a month around 30 days it is 2
670
that for two people that's room board
buffet those little towel swans um
shows
piano bars everything pools slides
uh i'll see you on board everybody thank
you so much
let's go on a cruise
can you imagine us on a cruise i mean
we've rv'ed we've been parked at this
desk for two years i'm serious let's go
on a cruise i can't think of anything
more fun and anyone more fun to do it
with i'm in i'm going to get you a
little uh lifesaver uh thing i'm going
to throw over you matching me we're in
girl can you imagine
[Music]
you